This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. During this holiday season, we have a special episode with two stories from one of my favorite writers, John Mualm. He is a contributing writer to the New York Times magazine and also a writer at large for pop-up magazine, and we're lucky to have had him on the show a few times. The first story is about the origin of the teddy bear, and it would be successor. And we also have this encore presentation of Wild One's Live, The Song, and Story Extravaganza that's probably my favorite thing that we broadcast,
这里是《99%看不见》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。在这个节日季，我们有一期特别节目，包含我最喜欢的作家之一约翰·莫瓦勒姆写的两个故事。他是《纽约时报杂志》的特约撰稿人，也是《弹出式杂志》的自由撰稿人，我们很幸运能请他来节目好几次。第一个故事关于泰迪熊的起源及其继任者。我们还有这场现场版“荒野奇兵：歌曲与故事狂欢”的重播，这可能是我播出的节目中最喜欢的一个，
and it deserves to be listened to numerous times. Here we go. It's totally unfair. Hydrox Cookies came out in 1908. Hydrox cookies came out in 1908. Oreos didn't show up until 4 years later, but it didn't matter. Hydrox could never shake the image of being a knockoff, and also ran. Hydrox lovers would champion its 10 year cream filling, vegetarians would praise them for being cruelty free while America's favorite cookie the Oreo contained animal art until the mid 90s. As a consumer product, it's just not up to you.
并且它值得被聆听许多次。我们开始吧。这完全不公平。Hydrox饼干于1908年问世。Hydrox饼干于1908年问世。奥利奥直到4年后才出现，但这没关系。Hydrox始终无法摆脱被视为山寨货和陪跑者的形象。Hydrox的爱好者会盛赞它长达10年的奶油夹心，素食主义者会称赞它们不涉及虐待动物，而美国人最爱的饼干奥利奥直到90年代中期都含有动物成分。作为消费品，这可由不得你。
Sometimes you're deemed the mighty transformer. And sometimes you're the loathsome go bot. One shall stand and one shall fall. It's capricious who wins. Swiss cake roll versus ho ho. swizzler versus red wine. Maybe yours was the first family on the block with the technologically superior beta max player, only to be overwhelmed by the mediocre VHS tape. Sometimes it doesn't make any sense at all.
有时候你被视为强大的变形金刚。有时你则是令人厌恶的機器人。一个留下，一个倒下。谁能赢纯属偶然。瑞士卷对决Ho Hos饼干。酸甜乐对决红酒。也许你是街区里第一家拥有技术上更优越的Beta磁带播放器的人，结果却被平庸的VHS录像带压倒了。有时这根本毫无道理。
But sometimes it does. I'm John Moalum. John is a writer for the New York Times magazine and a writer for Pop-Up Magazine, the live magazine in San Francisco where this story first appeared. Right, so it's 1902 and theodore Roosevelt is president and he decides to vacation in a town called Smeads in the Mississippi Woods where he can hunt black bear. He's a big outdoorsman, big hunter and this hunting trip became kind of a famous story. Basically, he had spent a few days hunting
但有时却又说得通。我是约翰·莫瓦勒姆。约翰是《纽约时报杂志》的撰稿人，也是旧金山现场杂志《弹出式杂志》的撰稿人，这个故事最初就是在那里面世的。好吧，那是1902年，西奥多·罗斯福担任总统，他决定去密西西比树林里一个叫斯米兹的小镇度假，在那里他可以猎黑熊。他是个狂热的户外运动爱好者、大猎手，这次狩猎之旅后来成了某种著名的故事。基本上，他花了几天时间打猎，
and I don't think they even saw a single bear. They definitely didn't get to shoot it any. And then one morning, the dogs get the scent of a bear and they follow it down into this really witty place where the president's guide says, you know what, don't even bother going in there and troubling yourself. I'll go in and I'll flush the bear out.
而且我觉得他们连一头熊都没看到。他们绝对没能开枪射中任何东西。然后有一天早晨，狗闻到了熊的气味，它们顺着气味追踪到一个非常泥泞的地方，总统的向导说，你知道吗，甚至不用费心去那个地方给自己找麻烦。我会进去把熊赶出来。
You just stay here and I'll flush it right to you. So, Roosevelt waits and waits, but then he gets bored and decides to go off and eat lunch. Eventually, the dogs do corner the bear and the guy not really knowing what to do, leaps off his horse, cracks the bear over the head with the butt of his rifle, knocks it unconscious or send me unconscious and ties it to a tree, and then starts blowing away on his bugle, trying to call Roosevelt back so that the president can be the one by the honor of shooting it. Roosevelt hears the vehicle and makes his way back to the hunting party. And what he finds is this bearer, it's a female bearer, it weighs about 235 pounds and it's tied to a tree. It's still semi-conscious, it's
你就待在这儿，我会把它直接赶向你。于是，罗斯福等啊等，但他随后感到无聊，决定离开去吃午饭。最终，狗确实把熊逼入了绝境，那家伙不知该如何是好，从马背上一跃而下，用步枪托狠狠砸在熊的头上，把它打得失去知觉或半失去知觉，然后把它绑在一棵树上，接着开始猛吹他的军号，试图把罗斯福叫回来，好让总统能获得开枪射击它的荣誉。罗斯福听到号声，回到了狩猎队伍中。而他发现的是这头熊，它是一头雌熊，重约235磅，被绑在树上。它仍然处于半清醒状态，它
injured, it looks a little mangy, it's actually probably about half as heavy and big as it should be, but there's been a real drought going on in the area. The bear looks pathetic, and Roosevelt takes pity on it. He decides that it's unsportsman-like to shoot this thing. He's not going to do it, and he doesn't want anyone else to do it either. So he lowers his gun, and in this sort of merciful moment is, you know, word of this spreads and a political cartoonist draws a cartoon of the moment of him, you know, showing the bear this mercy. And the way the cartoonist draws the bear is almost like a little Labrador puppy or a golden retriever puppy. It's sort of on its butt and its hind legs.
受了伤，看起来有点癞皮，实际上它的重量和体型可能只有正常的一半大，但该地区当时正经历严重的旱灾。这头熊看起来很可怜，罗斯福对它心生怜悯。他决定射杀这东西有失体育道德。他不打算这么做，也不想让其他人这么做。于是他放下枪，在这类仁慈的时刻，随着这个消息的传播，一位政治漫画家画了一幅漫画，描绘了他向这头熊展现这份仁慈的时刻。而漫画家画这头熊的方式几乎就像一只小拉布拉多幼犬或金毛寻回犬幼犬。它有点坐在屁股和后腿上。
And it's got these big round perked up ears, almost like Mickey Mouse and these wide eyes, and it's staring at the president waiting to see what its fate will be. The cartoon was called Drawing the Line in Mississippi, and from that basically spawned the teddy bear. This adorable little bear in the cartoon was turned into a three-dimensional plush toy. The very first teddy bear was either made by a German company called Steve, or a Brooklyn toy store owner, depending on who you ask. And they name it after Theodore Roosevelt. They call it Teddy's Bear. It's a huge sensation.
它有着大大的、圆圆的、竖起的耳朵，几乎就像米老鼠一样，还有大大的眼睛，它盯着总统，等待着它的命运会是什么。这幅漫画被称为《在密西西比划清界限》，而泰迪熊基本上就是由此诞生的。漫画中这只可爱的小熊被变成了一个三维毛绒玩具。根据你问的人不同，第一只泰迪熊要么是由一家名为史戴夫的德国公司制作的，要么是由布鲁克林的一家玩具店老板制作的。他们以西奥多·罗斯福的名字命名它。他们管它叫“特迪的熊”。这是一场巨大的轰动。
And it's actually more popular than Baby Dolls, which freaks everyone out a little bit. You know why should their children be playing with bears and not dolls? It's a little savage. And within a few years, I think Steve is producing close to a million teddy bears a year and shipping them to the US. But it was considered so bizarre that kids would play with a stuff bear that people just assumed it was a novelty and as soon as Roosevelt left office no one would want them anymore. At this time the whole idea of mass produced toys was also really new so the toy industry wanted to kind of capitalize on its rally and keep it going.
而且它实际上比娃娃更受欢迎，这让每个人都感到有点抓狂。你知道，为什么他们的孩子应该玩熊而不是娃娃？这有点野蛮。在短短几年内，我想史戴夫每年生产近百万只泰迪熊并将它们运往美国。但孩子们会玩毛绒熊被认为太离奇了，以至于人们只是认为这是一种新奇事物，一旦罗斯福卸任，就不会再有人想要它们了。当时大规模生产玩具的概念也真的很新，所以玩具行业希望某种程度上利用这股热潮并让它持续下去。
So it was really looking for whatever was going to be the next cuddly play thing that American kids were going to want. Although it had no idea what that might be. So fast forward in 1909 and Roosevelt's term is about up and the president elect is Roosevelt's handpicked successor William Howard Taft. In that January 1909 Taft is in Atlanta. He's trying to woo the South, try to convince him that his administration is gonna take them seriously as a constituency. And he's the guest of honor at this banquet. In the team of commerce in Atlanta decides
因此，它真的很想寻找无论什么将成为美国孩子们会想要的下一个可爱玩物。尽管它完全不知道那可能是什么。所以快进到1909年，罗斯福的任期即将结束，而当选总统是罗斯福亲自挑选的接班人威廉·霍华德·塔夫茨。在1909年那个一月，塔夫茨在亚特兰大。他正试图争取南方，试图让他们相信他的新政府会把他们作为一个选民群体认真对待。他是这场宴会上的荣誉嘉宾。亚特兰大的商业团队决定
it's going to serve him the truest, most unpretentious southern dish around. It's something that a writer of the time, I found this little book about southern food from the time, calls it the Christmas goose of the Epicurian Negro. The meal was possum and taters. And what it was was an opossum would be roasted on a bed of sweet potatoes and then presented whole
要为他端上一道最地道、最朴素的南方菜。这是当时的一位作家——我找到了这本关于当时南方食物的小册子——称之为“伊壁鸠鲁式黑人的圣诞鹅”的菜肴。这顿饭是负鼠配土豆。具体做法是，将一只负鼠放在一层红薯上烤熟，然后整只端上来，
on a platter with its head on, its tail on, and often you'd get a smaller little sweet potato cram between the animal's teeth, 50 teeth. By the way, 50 teeth is apparently the most teeth of any North American mammal, which is fascinating. In the end, the one that they brought to Taff's table weighed 18 pounds. All of a sudden, the orchestra strikes up and the guests burst into song. Suddenly, Taff is presented with a surprise gift, and it's a small, stuffed,
放在一个盘子里，带着头，带着尾巴，通常你还会得到一个小红薯塞在动物的牙齿中间，50颗牙齿。顺便说一句，50颗牙齿显然是所有北美哺乳动物中最多的牙齿，这太迷人了。最后，他们端到塔夫茨桌上的那只重达18磅。突然间，乐队奏起音乐，客人们突然唱起歌来。突然，塔夫茨收到了一件惊喜礼物，是一个小型填充的
apostantoid. And this is a brand new invention that some local tap supporters are trying to position as William Tap's presidency's answer to the teddy bear. They're calling it the Billy Possum. Already there was a company set up called the Georgia Billy Possum Company. According to one account, within 24 hours of that banquet, there are already deals being brokered for Billy Possums with distributors across the country. In covering the banquet, the LA Times announced that the Teddy Bear has been relegated to a seat in the rear, and for four years, possibly eight, the children of the United States will play with Billy Possum's. So, from then on, a bit of Possum Mania started.
负鼠玩具。这是一个全新的发明，一些当地的塔夫茨支持者正试图将它定位为威廉·塔夫茨总统对泰迪熊的回应。他们管它叫“比利负鼠”。当时已经成立了一家名为乔治亚比利负鼠公司的企业。根据一份记载，在那场宴会后的24小时内，已经开始与全国各地的分销商就比利负鼠达成交易。在报道这场宴会时，《洛杉矶时报》宣布泰迪熊已被降级到后排座位，在四年、可能八年的时间里，美国儿童将玩比利负鼠。因此，从那时起，一股负鼠狂热开始了。
There were Billy Possum postcards, Billy Possum pins, Billy Possum pictures for your cream when you had coffee. There was a ragtime tune called Possum the latest craze and as Taft traveled around the south some people actually started giving him live oppossums and cages when he would make public appearances sort of handing them over like they were floral with kids. Soon Billy Possums were in toy stores from New York to San Francisco. Because real apostles weren't actually that common in cities then and no one really knew what they were. A toy store in Brooklyn ran an in-store promotion with a live captive of Possum that they could show off to kids so the kids could familiarize
有比利负鼠明信片，比利负鼠别针，当你喝咖啡时用来放奶精的带有比利负鼠图片的器具。有一首名为《负鼠：最新狂热》的拉格泰姆曲子，随着塔夫茨在南方各地旅行，当他公开露面时，一些人实际上开始送给他活的关在笼子里的负鼠，有点像把它们当成花束交给孩子们一样。很快，从纽约到旧金山的玩具店里都有了比利负鼠的身影。因为真正的负鼠在当时的城市里其实并不常见，而且没有人真正知道它们是什么。布鲁克林的一家玩具店举办了一场店内促销活动，展出一只被俘获的活负鼠，向孩子们展示，这样孩子们就能熟悉
themselves with what this new animal they were going to be best friends with was. I found an advertisement for the store that read, do not let it be said that any man, woman, or child, and Brooklyn has not seen the cute little animal, whose name is mentioned more in all parts of the world today than any other. Previously, there had been poems and newspapers sort of mourning the passing of the dolls and how sad it was
他们即将成为最好朋友的这个新动物是什么。我找到了该店的一则广告，上面写着：“不要让任何人说，布鲁克林有哪个男人、女人或孩子，还没有见过这只可爱的小动物，它的名字今天在世界各地受到的提及比任何其他动物都多。”在此之前，报纸上曾出现过一些诗歌，某种程度上哀悼娃娃的消亡，以及这些泰迪熊进入托儿所并征服它们是多么令人悲伤。
that these teddy bears were coming into nurseries and fanquishing them. And now there are poems in newspapers about Billy Possum's displacing teddy bears. But since you probably never heard of a Billy Possum, you can guess what comes next. It was a total flop, and the Billy Possum was forgotten and almost entirely out of stores within a couple of months. So in other words, the Billy Possum never even made almost entirely out of stores within a couple of months. So in other words, the Billy Possum never even made it to see Christmas time, which is a special kind of tragedy for Toy.
而现在，报纸上出现了关于比利负鼠取代泰迪熊的诗歌。但既然你可能从未听说过比利负鼠，你就能猜到接下来会发生什么。这是一个彻底的失败，比利负鼠被遗忘了，在几个月内几乎完全从商店里消失了。换句话说，比利负鼠甚至没有撑到看到圣诞节，这对于玩具来说是一种特殊的悲剧。
There are several possible explanations as to why the Billy Possum never took off. The first, and probably what you're thinking right now, is this, O Possums are ugly and nobody likes them. But it was also the dawn of the mechanical toy, and even some teddy bears that evolved into wind up animatrons. There was a French-made teddy bear that, quote, winds up and is calculated to indulge in
关于比利负鼠为什么没有流行起来，有几种可能的解释。第一种，也是你现在可能正在想的，是这样的：负鼠很丑，没有人喜欢它们。但这也是机械玩具的黎明，甚至有些泰迪熊演变成了发条动植物。有一只法国制造的泰迪熊，引述：“能上发条，并且注定要进行
a number of ludicrous summer salts. How could a limp stuffed Billy Possum compete with that? But John Moilum argues that at its heart, the acceptance of Teddy Bear and the rejection of the Lee Possum comes down to their origin stories. In the story that was told about Roosevelt and this bear, it was a very kind of tender moment where Roosevelt was showing the bear mercy and when you looked at that cartoon the way the bear was drawn, it looked like something that you would want to just sweep up into your arms and take care of and that was vulnerable and that needed your help. It looked like a teddy bear as we know it, although no one knew it at the time. The story with Taft, it didn't give it anything
一系列滑稽的空翻。”一个软绵绵的填充比利负鼠怎么能与那个竞争呢？但约翰·莫瓦勒姆认为，本质上，对泰迪熊的接受和对比利负鼠的拒绝归结于它们的起源故事。在关于罗斯福和这头熊的故事中，这是一个非常温柔的时刻，罗斯福对这头熊表现出了怜悯，当你看着那幅漫画时，熊的画法看起来就像某种你想直接抱进怀里照顾的东西，它是脆弱的，需要你的帮助。它看起来就像我们所知的泰迪熊，尽管当时没有人知道这一点。而关于塔夫茨的故事，它并没有带来任何
else. Taft ate his apostle for supper and he ate a lot of it and he ate so much that after his first several helping, a doctor seated nearby apparently passed him a note suggesting that it might be a good idea if he slowed down a little. Taft even bragged to reporters the next day about how much possum he consumed. Well, I like a possum, and I ate very heartily of it last night, and it did not disturb in the slightest my digestion or my sleep. The possum was vulnerable, I guess, to split out on a bed of taters, but you're not exactly rooting for it.
其他东西。塔夫茨把他的负鼠当晚餐吃了，而且他吃了很多，他吃得那么多，以至于在他吃了好几份之后，坐在附近的一位医生显然递给他一张纸条，建议他如果吃慢一点可能会是个好主意。塔夫茨第二天甚至向记者吹嘘他吃了多少负鼠。嗯，我喜欢负鼠，昨晚我吃得非常痛快，它一点也没有打扰我的消化或睡眠。这只负鼠很脆弱，我想，被剖开摆在一床土豆上，但你绝对不是在为它加油打气。
I started feeling really bad for Taft, who, you know, the more I read a little bit about him, he was this totally colorless politician, and he didn't actually even want to be president by some accounts. He was sort of strong armed into it by Roosevelt, and he never really measured up to Roosevelt's charisma and charm. I mean, Roosevelt was the kind of guy who,
我开始对塔夫茨感到非常同情，你知道，我对他了解得越多，他就是一个完全毫无特色可言的政客，而且根据一些说法，他实际上甚至不想当总统。他某种程度上是被罗斯福强推上这个位置的，而且他从来没有真正达到罗斯福的个人魅力和吸引力。我的意思是，罗斯福就是那种人，
you know, no matter what he did, history seemed eager to glorify him for it. Case in point, the messed up thing about the famous story of Teddy's bear on that hunting trip in Mississippi isn't even the whole truth. You have to remember that Roosevelt was a hunter. He was there to hunt bears. He wasn't a PETA activist or something like this. While he did show the bear mercy, it was a very particular kind of mercy. After
你知道，无论他做什么，历史似乎都渴望为他歌功颂德。典型的例子是，关于密西西比那场狩猎之旅中泰迪熊著名故事的糟糕之处，甚至不是全部真相。你必须记住，罗斯福是个猎人。他去那里是为了打猎。他不是PETA（善待动物组织）的活动家或类似的人。虽然他确实对这熊表现出了仁慈，但这是一种非常特殊的仁慈。在
he refused to shoot it, he said, put it out of its misery. And then one of his hunting buddies came in and slipped the bear's neck open with a knife. They carried the bear's body back to camp over the back of a horse, and they basically ate off it for the next several days. And on the last night of their trip, they finished it off, they roasted its paws, and I could you not bathe the paws with a side of possumentators. So that's why you will never cuddle up with a billy possum. Just like you will never watch a beta max tape, or travel to gobitron with leader one, and you will never again dunk a Hydrox
他拒绝射杀它之后，他说，给它个痛快吧。然后他的一位狩猎伙伴走上前，用一把刀割开了熊的脖子。他们把熊的尸体驮在马背上带回了营地，并在接下来的几天里基本上把它当饭吃完了。在他们旅程的最后一天，他们吃光了最后一点，烤了熊爪，我没有骗你，熊爪配着一份负鼠配土豆。这就是为什么你永远不会去抱抱一只比利负鼠。就像你永远不会去看Beta磁带，或者和领袖一号一起去Gobotron，你也永远不会再浸泡Hydrox
cookie. Manimus Hydrox Cookies. They were really tasty. We have one cardinal rule on 99% invisible. No cardinals, meaning we don't deal with the natural world, only the built world. So when I read John Mwellen's brilliant book called Wild Ones, a sometimes dismaying,
饼干。天哪，Hydrox饼干。它们真的很好吃。我们在《99%看不见》有一个核心原则。没有红衣主教（cardinals），意思是我们的节目不涉及自然界，只涉及人工建造的世界。所以当我读到约翰·莫瓦勒姆那本名为《荒野奇兵》的出色书时，那是一个有时令人沮丧、
weirdly reassuring story about looking at people, looking at animals in America, I didn't think I'd ever do an episode of 99% of visible about it. I just read it for fun. But then I saw John perform stories from the book Live with musical accompaniment, and I thought, I need to put this on the radio. I still call this radio. Anyway, what you need to know about Wild Ones is that it isn't a book about nature.
却又莫名让人安心的故事，讲述了在美利坚观察人们观察动物的经历，我从没想过我会做一期关于它的《99%看不见》节目。我读它只是为了好玩。但后来我看到约翰现场表演书中的故事，伴随着音乐伴奏，我心想，我得把它搬上广播。我仍然把这叫广播。无论如何，你需要了解的关于《荒野奇兵》的是，它不是一本关于自然的书。
It's a book about how we fit nature into our modern lives. Wild Ones is about the cutesy stuffed animals, the eco tours, and the Byzantine methods of conservation that evolve when our experience with wildlife goes from something natural to something designed. Human animal interaction has become a designed experience, and the story of that transition, as the title of the book suggests, is sometimes dismayed, and also weirdly reassuring. John Mwellem is friends with the band Black Prairie, and as he was writing the book, they can cock to this idea of the band creating a soundtrack to the book, and the result was an extended EP called Wild Wands. A musical score for the things you might see in your head when you reflect on certain characters and incidents that you read in the book. The writer and the band then went on a short
它是一本关于我们如何将自然融入我们现代生活的书。荒野奇兵讲述的是可爱的毛绒动物、生态旅游，以及当我们与野生动物的体验从自然事物转变为设计事物时演变出的繁复的保护方法。人与动物的互动已经变成了一种设计的体验，而这种转变的故事，正如书名所暗示的那样，有时令人沮丧，但也莫名地令人安心。约翰·莫瓦勒姆是“黑草原”乐队的朋友，当他在写这本书时，他们构思了这个想法：乐队为这本书创作配乐，结果是一张名为《荒野奇兵》的扩展EP。这是一份音乐总谱，对应着当你回想起书中读到的某些人物和事件时，你脑海中可能会看到的画面。这位作家和乐队随后带着这首歌和故事狂欢节进行了一次短途巡演，
tour with the song and story extravaganza that I'm going to play for you today. When I saw them perform this live in San Francisco, I freaked out it was so good and I costed them in the dressing room and said, you have to let me share this with my audience. So here it is. And here we go. 2 %, 1 %, 1 %, 1 %, 1 %, 1 %, 1 %, 1 %, 1 %, 1 %, 1 %, 1 %, 1 %, 1 %, 1 %, 1 %, 1 %, 1 %, 1 %, 1 %, 1 %, 1 %, 1 %, 1 %, 1 %, 1 %, 1 %, 1 %, 1 %, 1 %, 1 %, 1 %, 1 %, 1 %, 1 %, 1 %, 1 %, 1 %, 1 %, 1 %, 1 %, 1 %, 1 %, 1 %, 1 %, 1, 2%, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1 I'm going to be a little bit more careful. I'm going to be a little bit more careful. I'm going to be a little bit more careful. I'm going to be a little bit more careful. I'm going to be a little bit more careful. I'm going to be a little bit more careful. I'm going to be a little bit more careful. I'm going to be a little bit more careful.
今天我要为大家播放的就是这个。当我看到他们在旧金山现场表演这个时，我惊呆了，太棒了，我在后台休息室缠着他们说：“你必须让我与我的听众分享这个。”所以它就在这里。我们开始吧。2%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，10%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，10%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，1%，100%匹配。
I'm going to be a little bit more careful. I'm going to be a little bit more careful. I'm going to be a little bit more careful. I'm going to be a little bit more careful. I'm going to be a little bit more careful. I'm so glad I was able to see you. I'm so glad I was able to see you. I'm so glad I was able to see you. I'm so glad I was able to see you. I'm so glad I was able to see you.
我会更加小心。我会更加小心。我会更加小心。我会更加小心。我会更加小心。我很高兴能见到你。我很高兴能见到 you. 我很高兴能见到你。我很高兴能见到你。我很高兴能见到你。
I'm so glad I was able to see you. I'm so glad I was able to see you. I'm so glad I was able to see you. I'm so glad I was able to see you. I'm so glad I was able to see you. I'm so glad I was able to see you. I'm so glad I was able to see you. I'm so glad I was able to see you. It It happens every summer. Small turtles called Diamondback Terrapins skitter out of the water around JFK airport
我很高兴能见到你。我很高兴能见到你。我很高兴能见到 you. 我很高兴能见到你。我很高兴能见到你。我很高兴能见到你。我很高兴能见到你。我很高兴能见到你。它每年夏天都会发生。被称为菱斑水龟的小海龟从肯尼迪机场周围的水中爬出来
in New York. They start moving west. They're heading for a patch of sand where they like to lay their eggs, and they have to cross over one of the airports runways to get there. Runway 4L. Sometimes, there's so many turtles on the move it wants that the control tower has to delay flights. Now the press loves doing stories about how funny this is, how a fleet of giant airplanes can be held up by just a few tiny turtles. But hold that picture in your mind and think about the Caribbean Sea in 1492. There were almost a billion sea turtles living in it back then.
在纽约。它们开始向西移动。它们正朝着一块它们喜欢产卵的沙地前进，它们必须穿过其中一条机场跑道才能到达那里。4L跑道。有时，移动的海龟实在是太多了，以至于控制塔不得不推迟航班。现在，媒体很喜欢报道这有多么有趣，庞大的飞机机队怎么会被几只微小的海龟阻挡。但请把这幅画面记在心里，想想1492年的加勒比海。那时那里生活着将近十亿只海龟。
Columbus's men anchored in the Caribbean, wrote about being kept to wake at night by the thwacking of so many turtle shells against the sides of their ship. Notice how that scene is the exact opposite of the scene at JFK. It's not a fleet of giant airplanes being held up by a few tiny turtles. It's a giant fleet of turtles bombarding just a few relatively tiny ships. So I wrote this book about people and wild animals in America and it only really started because I wanted to show my daughter in danger species in the wild before they disappeared. Like a lot of people I think, I felt this pain. I knew that all around us, beautiful parts of the world are expiring.
哥伦布的手下在加勒比海抛锚，他们在文章中写到，夜晚被无数海龟壳拍打船舷的声音吵得无法入睡。注意那个场景与肯尼迪机场的场景完全相反。那不是一支庞大的飞机机队被几只微小的海龟阻挡。这是一支庞大的海龟舰队在轰击几艘相对微小的船只。所以我写了这本书，关于美国的人类和野生动物，它真正开始的原因只是因为我想在濒危物种消失之前向我的女儿展示野外的濒危物种。我想很多人都一样，我感受到了这种痛苦。我知道在我们周围，世界美丽的角落正在消亡。
And I also knew that people in the future, they might not even notice. For them, a world without whales or wilderness, might feel normal. I wanted to counteract that forgetting that's bound to take hold over time. This forgetting has a name. Scientists call it shifting baselines syndrome. It means that all of us accept the version of the world we inherit as normal. Over the years we watch forests get locked or animals disappear, but when the next generation comes along, they accept
我也知道未来的人们甚至可能不会注意到这一点。对他们来说，一个没有鲸鱼或荒野的世界可能会让人感觉很正常。我想抵制这种随着时间推移必然发生的遗忘。这种遗忘有一个名字。科学家称之为基线漂移综合症。这意味着我们所有人都接受了我们继承的世界版本作为正常状态。多年来，我们看着森林被砍伐或动物消失，但当下一代到来时，他们接受了
that depleted version of nature is their normal. It's hard to zoom out, really feel the changes that are stacking up across the generations. I can't even imagine what an ocean filled with a billion sea turtles unless feel like. Last winter, I was in Hawaii, and I saw three seaterals, and I flipped the f*** out. I felt like I was in Eden. It wasn't so long ago though that America was a kind of eat when people could be dwarfed and engulfed by wild animals in a way that feels almost impossible now. In the late 1800s, trains with sometimes had to stop for four or five hours as streams of buffalo moved across the tracks.
这种枯竭的自然版本是他们的常态。很难缩小视野，真正去感受跨代累积的变化。我甚至无法想象充满十亿只海龟的海洋会是什么感觉。去年冬天，我在夏威夷看到了三只海龟，我整个人都激动得要命。我觉得自己置身于伊甸园。不过，不久前，美国还是一种人类可能会被野生动物矮化和吞没的土地，这种方式在今天看来几乎是不可能的。在19世纪后期，火车有时不得不停下四到五个小时，因为成群的美洲野牛横穿铁轨。
Occasionally, a stampede would batter into the side of a train derailing it. A witness described one of these scenes, 1871 in Kansas. Each individual of Buffalo went at it with a desperation and despair of punching against between local boat cars, just as blind madness chants directed after having dreams thrown off the track twice a one-week conductors learned to have a very decided respect for the inuosyncrasies of the Buffalo. This man's name was William Temple Horneday. He was a fantastic midwesterner with an elaborate mustache. Horn today was head
有时，一场狂奔会撞击火车的一侧，导致其脱轨。一位目击者描述了其中一个场景，1871年在堪萨斯州。每一只野牛都以绝望的心态冲撞着当地的勒紧车厢，就像盲目的疯狂咒语在每周两次被抛出轨道后，列车长们学会了对野牛的怪癖保持极大的敬意。这个人的名字叫威廉·坦普尔·霍纳迪。他是中西部人，留着精致的胡子。霍纳迪是
taxi-dermist at the Smithsonian and he traveled the globe, hunting exotic animals and stuffing them for the museum. In India, after he took down an elephant, climbed to top the carcass and popped open a bass ale. Once he trapped in a rangatang, named it Little Man, gave it to Andrew Carnegie as a pet. It sounds weird, but for Hornetay, killing these animals was a kind of conservation. He believed by stuffing them, he was preserving endangered species and for the future generations that might not know them after they were gone. Through taxidermy, he could make them immortal. In 1886, Horneday looked west and saw that Americans were killing so many buffaloes,
史密森尼学会的首席剥制师，他游历全球，猎杀珍奇动物并为博物馆制作标本。在印度，他击倒一头大象后，爬上尸体顶部，打开了一瓶黑麦啤酒。有一次，他捉住了一只红毛猩猩，给它起名叫“小人”，并把它作为宠物送给安德鲁·卡内基。这听起来很奇怪，但对霍纳迪来说，杀死这些动物是一种保护。他相信通过制作标本，他是在为那些在它们消失后可能不认识它们的后代保护濒危物种。通过动物剥制术，他可以让它们永生。1886年，霍纳迪向西望去，发现美国人正在杀死如此多的野牛，
so rapidly that the prairie was almost empty. He figured there were maybe less than 300 buffalo left in the wild. And so he did what he thought was the most helpful and logical thing. He lit out from Montana to kill several dozen of them. ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ La la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la born. But from there, his thinking evolved. He realized he was basically just a funeral director, embalming the species that America was exterminating. It occurred to him. What have we actually tried to keep these animals alive? And so he became one of America's first real wildlife conservationists, an activist, a lobbyist, a celebrity. America was killing every conceivable kind of animal in their way, and Hornetay stood
速度如此之快，以至于大草原几乎空无一人。他估计野外可能只剩下不到300头野牛了。于是他做了他认为最有用、最符合逻辑的事情。他从蒙大拿州出发，杀了几打野牛。拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉拉。出生。但从那时起，他的思想发生了演变。他意识到他基本上只是一个殡仪馆，为美国正在消灭的物种进行防腐处理。这让他想到了。如果我们真的努力让这些动物活着会怎么样？于是他成为了美国最早真正的野生动物保护主义者之一，一个活动家，一个游说者，一个名人。美国在挡路时杀死了所有你能想象到的动物，而霍纳迪坚定地站出来
up for all of them, and mycons like the grizzly, to lollier, less majestic things, like the squirrel. A life squirrel to tree is poetry and motion. We asked every American to let the hand to say the silver tail. There was really only one animal on the continent that Hornetay wasn't worried about. It was seemed too mighty to be brought down by men with guns, and it lived in a cold and brutal wilderness that men couldn't possibly take over.
为了他们所有人，从像灰熊这样的大型动物，到像松鼠这样不那么宏伟的小东西。树上的松鼠是运动中的诗歌。我们要求每个美国人伸出援手拯救银尾。大陆上其实只有一种动物是霍纳迪不担心的。它似乎太强大了，不会被拿着枪的人击倒，而且它生活在一个人类根本无法接管的寒冷而残酷的荒野中。
Polar Bear was the king of the frozen Earth. It's not very probable that the polar bear will ever be exterminated by man. That's Hornetay, writing in 1914. Back then, no one could have imagined the problem as abstract as climate change. But think about how quickly climate change has changed the polar bear's reputation in our minds. It's gone from bloodthirsty man killer to delicate drowning victim. 200 years ago, Arctic explorers wrote about polar bears leaping into their boats and trying to eat them, even if they lit the bear on fire.
北极熊是冰冻地球之王。北极熊绝不可能被人类消灭。这是霍纳迪在1914年写下的。当时，没有人能想象到像气候变化这样抽象的问题。但想想气候变化在我们的心中以多么快的速度改变了北极熊的声誉。它已经从嗜血的食人杀手变成了脆弱的溺水受害者。200年前，北极考察队员在文章中写到北极熊跳进他们的船并试图吃掉他们，甚至他们把熊点燃。
But recently, when I went to the tiny northern town that calls itself the polar bear a capital of the world, Martha Stewart had just arrived to film the animals for her daytime show on the Hallmark channel. The town is called Churchill Manitoba. It's on the edge of Hudson Bay. In every fall, right before the bay freezes over, Churchill gets overrun with about 900 polar bears and 10,000 polar bear tourists. Bears routinely wander into town, they like hanging out at the elementary school, especially. Folks can call 675 Bear and a squad of bear patrol officers will come chase the animals back onto the tundra and their trups. Bears that won't budge are tranquilized and shipped out to a quonset hunt near the airport.
但最近，当我来到那个自称世界北极熊之都的小北方小镇时，玛莎·斯图尔特刚到那里，为她在霍尔马克频道的日间节目拍摄这些动物。这个小镇叫丘吉尔曼尼托巴。它在哈德逊湾的边缘。每年秋天，就在海湾结冰之前，丘吉尔挤满了大约900只北极熊和10,000名北极熊游客。熊经常会闲逛到镇上，它们特别喜欢在小学闲逛。人们可以拨打675 Bear，一队熊巡逻队就会过来把动物赶回苔原和它们的陷阱里。不肯动弹的熊会被注射镇静剂，并被运送到机场附近的一个雷达穹顶狩猎场。
Once this so-called polar bear jail fills up, each animal is drugged again and airlifted one at a time to an area north of town. and I went to one myself. There was something just a little ceremonial about the bear lift I went to. How the uniformed wildlife officer has arranged the sleeping bear on a net at the center of the crowd. How they tucked its paws carefully across its chest like some drunken uncle after Thanksgiving dinner. It was so careful, beautiful,
一旦这个所谓的北极熊监狱装满了，每只动物就会再次被麻醉，并被一次一只地空运到镇北的一个地区。我自己去过一个。我去的那个熊空运活动带有一点仪式感。全副武装的野生动物官员如何在人群中心的网上安排熟睡的熊。他们如何像感恩节晚餐后某个喝醉了的叔叔一样，把它的爪子仔细地交叉在胸前。它是如此小心、美丽、
and confusing. A couple of people cried. It was like the opposite of an animal sacrifice, a ritual to save the bearer, to show how far out of our way we'd go not to kill it. I stood there and watched, and as I did, Martha Stewart stood next to me. Her crew was there filming everything. Honestly, it's a breathtaking thing to watch, a polar bear flying away. All of a sudden the helicopter started to churn. The edges of the net lifted. The furry shape inside contracted to you
和困惑。有几个人哭了。这就像动物献祭的反面，一种拯救熊的仪式，以表明为了不杀死它，我们会做出多大的努力。我站在那里看着，当我这样做时，玛莎·斯图尔特站在我旁边。她的船员在那里拍摄一切。老实说，看着一只北极熊飞走是一件令人叹为观止的事情。突然间，直升机开始转动。网的边缘升起了。里面的毛茸茸形状收缩到你
and then the entire package was off the ground. The helicopter climbed toward a cloud bank. The bear twirling slightly underneath it like a teethe bag. And then finally the polar bear was gone. Yeah, I know, airlifting polar bears. Strange, no one could have imagined it would come to this. But the way we help animals now has evolved into a surreal kind of performance art. We carry migrating salmanners across busy highways. We monitor pygmy rabbits with drones. At Cornell, scientists breeding endangered peregrine falcons
然后整个包裹离开地面。直升机向云层爬升。熊在它下面微微旋转，就像一个茶包。最后北极熊消失了。是的，我知道，空运北极熊。奇怪，没有人会想到事情会变成这样。但我们现在帮助动物的方式已经演变成一种超现实的表演艺术。我们用繁忙的高速公路运送迁徙的鲑鱼。我们用无人机监测侏儒兔。在康奈尔大学，科学家们繁殖濒危游隼
were especially made receptacle. They called the Coculation Hats, coaxed a bird named Burecane, to ejaculate on their heads several times a day every day for much of the 1970s. See, this is another baseline that shifts over time. The lengths were willing to go. Each generation does what would have looked like fighting for a preposterous lost cause to the one before.
是一个特别制作的容器。他们称之为“交配帽”，在20世纪70年代的大部分时间里，每天多次诱使一只名叫伯勒坎的鸟在他们的头上射精。看，这是另一个随时间变化的基线。我们愿意付出的代价。每一代人都做着在前人看来像是为荒谬的失败事业而战的事情。
And then each generation comes along anew and does a little bit more than that. And on it goes, humanity is strapping on the proverbial population now. Again, and again, and again. Consider the story of George and Tex. In the late 1970s there only a handful of looping cranes left in the wild, and also a small number at a government lab in Maryland. Scientists there were doing their best to ring as many new offspring as they could from those captive birds.
然后每一代人都会重新出现，做更多的事情。事情就这样继续下去了，人类正在把这个众所周知的种族重新戴上。一次又一次，一次又一次。想想乔治和特克斯的故事。在20世纪70年代末，野外只剩下少数几只美洲鹤，政府在马里兰州的一个实验室里也有少量这种鹤。那里的科学家们正在尽最大努力从那些圈养的鸟类中产出尽可能多的新后代。
But the lab had one problem child, a female crane named Tex. As a newborn Tex had been raised in a cardboard box in the zookeepers living room and having never seen another crane crane she imprinted on the one animal she did see the zookeeper. Basically she wound up sexually attracted to people and not other cranes. The scientists kept trying to pair a text off but text wasn't interested. She wanted a man and specifically a man who looked like her old zookeeper, a dark-haired white man, a medium-build. Now, there was a young crane conservationist named George Archibald, and George happened
但实验室里有一个问题儿童，一只名叫特克斯的雌鹤。作为一只新生儿，特克斯是在动物管理员起居室的一个纸板箱里长大的，由于从未见过另一只鹤，她对她唯一看到的动物——动物管理员产生了印记。基本上，她最终对人产生了性吸引力，而不是其他鹤。科学家们不断尝试为特克斯配对，但特克斯并不感兴趣。她想要一个男人，特别是长得像她老动物管理员的男人，一个黑发白人，中等身材。现在，有一个年轻的鹤类保护主义者叫乔治·阿奇博尔德，而乔治恰好
to be a dark-haired white man, a medium-build. He took text to rural Wisconsin, put a mattress in her tent, and moved in as Texas companion. They'd forge together, build a S, and they'd dance. George doing deep knee bends and springing up with thorns out like wing. He'd wook, Benholler, come on text, come on, come on text, and soon they'd be dancing together just like wild cranes do during courtship. This would get texts aroused and it just the right moment to assistance would rush out from a hiding place and artificially inseminator with cranes even. Living with text for months at a time because the eggs she kept laying were in fertile. The man in crane would start out after dawn, they'd go for a walk, and they'd dance.
是一个黑发白人，中等身材。他把特克斯带到威斯康星州农村，在她的帐篷里放了一张床垫，作为特克斯的同伴搬了进去。他们会一起觅食，建造一个S，然后跳舞。乔治做深蹲，并用像翅膀一样的刺弹起来。他会发出“本霍勒，来吧特克斯，来吧，来吧特克斯”的喊叫，很快他们就会像野生求爱期间的野鹤一样一起跳舞。这会激起特克斯的欲望，就在合适的时刻，助手们会从藏身处冲出来，用鹤甚至对她进行人工授精。与特克斯同住了好几个月，因为她不断产下的卵是没有生育能力的。这个人和鹤会在黎明后出发，他们去散步，跳舞。
They'd dance, and they'd dance, and they'd dance. George didn't enjoy any of this. He was miserable, actually miserable, but in the spring of 1983, text finally laid an egg that hatched, and George was right there when it did. He was invited on the tonight show to celebrate one headline read, man, crane, proud parents of Chick. George named the Chick-G-Wiz. By now, G-Wiz has 44 grandchildren and great grandchildren. Today, there are more whooping grains in the wild than there have been in almost a hundred years. William Temple Ornidae, the taxidermist, died in 1937. At his funeral, buglers from the local Boy Scout troop surrounded the coffin and played
他们跳舞，跳舞，跳舞。乔治一点也不喜欢这一切。他实际上很痛苦，非常痛苦，但在1983年春天，特克斯终于产下了一颗孵化出来的蛋，乔治就在现场。他被邀请到今夜秀上庆祝，一个标题写着：男人、鹤、小鸡的自豪父母。乔治给小鸡起名叫G-Wiz。到目前为止，G-Wiz有44个孙子和曾孙。今天，野外的美洲鹤比近一百年来的任何时候都要多。标本制作师威廉·坦普尔·奥尼达于1937年去世。在他的葬礼上，当地童子军的号手们围着棺材吹奏
home on the range. Twenty years later, workers at the Smithsonian were dismantling Hornet A's buffalo exhibit, the one he built after the hunt in Montana, the one he thought would last forever. They found a rusty box buried in the fake ground. Inside was a letter. It was from Hornet A, written to his future successor at the museum. Dear sir, what I am Dustin Ashes, I beg you to protect these specimens from the deterioration of destruction.
《原野之家》。二十年後，史密森尼学会的工作人员正在拆除霍纳·A的野牛展品，也就是他在蒙大拿州狩猎后建造的那一个，那个他以为会永远存在的那一个。他们在假地下发现了一个生锈的盒子。里面有一封信。那是霍纳迪写给他在博物馆的未来继承人的。亲爱的先生，当我化为尘土和骨灰时，我恳求你保护这些标本免受毁灭的退化。
At last, the game boosters of the Great West have stopped killing the Buffalo. All the Buffalo are dead. I tried, I tried, dear sir I write this letter to you, Reload, give the devil his doom Dear sir, I am happy not to be alive, to see you have to see. Dear sir, I have prepared for the worst, and their beauty, kill by, was true. Dear Son, I have protected them now to thee, high as debris of dear sin, I have now stopped the killing. They're all gone, here for you to soon. ...to the sea. I'll give them a home.
最后，大西部的猎物推动者已经停止杀死野牛。所有的野牛都死了。我试过了，我试过了，亲爱的先生，我给你写了这封信，重新加载，给恶魔他的厄运。亲爱的先生，我很高兴还活着，看看你必须看到的。亲爱的先生，我已经做好了最坏的打算，他们的美丽，被杀死，是真的。亲爱的儿子，我现在保护他们免受高处的残骸，亲爱的罪孽，我现在已经停止了杀戮。他们都走了，很快就留给你了。...去大海。我会给他们一个家。
Please keep them a home. I am dust and bone, you can move faster than faster than wild ones can Oh Oh Please keep them from home, home give them a heart. I understand what you can do faster than, As do them while one is here Of course, Hornet had written that pessimistic letter in 1887 when he was still just a young taxi dermist. Turns out he was wrong, the buffalo were not all dead, and in the years to come, he actually played a big role in helping to save them. Lots of other species too. But it was hard for him to focus on those successes. He'd lost so many more battles than he wanted.
请给他们一个家。我是尘土和骨灰，你移动得比野生动物更快哦哦请让他们远离家园，家给他们一颗心。我明白你能比野生动物更快做什么，当野生动物在这里时，当然，霍纳迪在1887年写下这封悲观的信时，他仍然只是一个年轻的剥制师。事实证明他错了，野牛并没有全部死去，在接下来的几年里，他在帮助拯救它们方面实际上发挥了重要作用。还有很多其他物种。但他很难专注于这些成功。他失去了比他想象的更多的战斗。
By the end of his life, he turned bitter to solution. I tried to eject the courage into the hearts of men, but today, I think that speaking generally, civilized man is an unmitigated ass. Like all of us, his imagination was hopelessly trapped in its own moment, its own lifetime. You can only see the world through the tiny keyhole of the present. So where does that leave us then, in our present? Maybe all any one of us can do is push against the baseline as it shifts. We can be a tiny counterweight. We weigh almost nothing.
在他生命快结束时，他变得愤世嫉俗。我曾试图将勇气注入人们的心中，但今天，我认为总的来说，文明人是个十足的笨蛋。和我们所有人一样，他的想象力无可救药地困在自己的时代、自己的一生中。你只能透过当下的微小钥匙孔看世界。那么，这让我们在当下处于什么位置呢？也许我们每个人能做的，就是在基准线移动时去推动它。我们可以成为一个小小的反作用力。我们的重量几乎为零。
The generation after generation that weight adds up. Sometimes in some places the baseline starts to shift from the other direction, in the direction of more being, not less. But that happens in Cremenore 2 and it can be hard to notice. So picture that scene at JFK again, all those turtles. When Hornet it was born, they were close to extinction, being hunted because they tasted so good and soup. We're like those turtles, a race of stubborn little things that barely notices as the wilderness it migrates through, fills up with villages and lights, and swells into an
代复一代，这种重量不断累积。有时在某些地方，基准线开始从另一个方向移动，朝着更多存在而非更少存在的方向发展。但这发生在克雷梅诺尔2号，而且很难被注意到。所以，再次想象一下肯尼迪机场的那个场景，那些海龟。当霍内特出生时，它们已经濒临灭绝，因为它们的肉太好吃了而被猎杀并做成汤。我们就像那些海龟，一个顽强的小群体，几乎没有注意到它迁徙的荒野正布满村庄和灯光，并膨胀成一个
airport runway. Just keep migrating across it anyway, tucking the eggs of the next generation into the sand. And we're like the airplanes too, because we have chains. We've changed into something that Horniday couldn't ever imagine, species that can at least try to slow down, try to stop. I like to think about those airplanes powering down, the lines of them parting like a shiny metallic sea. So this tiny tribe of turtles can pass through.
机场跑道。无论如何，继续穿过它迁徙，把下一代的卵藏进沙子里。我们也像飞机，因为我们有链条。我们已经变成了霍纳代做梦也想不到的样子，一个至少可以试图放慢脚步、试图停下来的物种。我喜欢想象那些飞机减弱动力，它们的行列像闪亮的金属海洋一样分开。这样这个小小海龟部落就可以通过了。
I get it, it looks funny in the present, but squint into the hazy panorama of history. Those airplanes idling in place, that little moment of not moving forward, looks unmistakably to me like progress La la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la That's John Fowellum, we're up to take a break if you're back, thanks so much. That was Wild One's Life, text written by John Moellum, music by Black Prairie. Black Prairie is Jenny Conley Driesos on accordion and vocals. Chris Funk on Banjo Dobro on a harp and vocals. John Moellon on drums and vocals.
我明白，在当下这看起来很有趣，但眯起眼睛凝视历史那朦胧的全景。那些闲置在原地的飞机，那静止片刻的时刻，在我看来毫无疑问就是进步啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦，那是约翰·福勒姆，如果您回来了，我们要休息一下，非常感谢。那是《野人生活》，由约翰·穆伦作词，黑草原乐队演奏。黑草原乐队有珍妮·康利·德里索斯负责手风琴和主唱。克里斯·方克负责班卓琴、多布罗吉他、竖琴和主唱。约翰·穆伦负责鼓和主唱。
John Newfeld on guitar and vocals. Nate Query on bass. An Analyza Tornfeld on Fiddling vocals. Their recording engineer is Rich Hip. Black Prairie has a new-ish album called Fortune that I know you'll like, and Annalisa from the band has an upcoming solo record called The Number 8 that you can pre-order online, and I'm going to have a link to that on our website 99pi.org. 99% invisible is Sam Greenspan, Katie Mingle,
约翰·纽菲尔德负责吉他与主唱。内特·奎里负责贝斯。安娜莉莎·托恩菲尔德负责小提琴与主唱。他们的录音师是里奇·希普。黑草原乐队有一张名为《财富》的新专辑，我知道你们会喜欢，乐队的安娜莉莎即将推出一张名为《数字8》的个人唱片，你们可以在网上预订，我会在我们的网站 99pi.org 上提供链接。《99%隐形》由萨姆·格林斯潘、凯蒂·明格尔、
Avery Troubleman, and me Roman Mars. It's been a really spectacular year for us at the show. Thank you so much for your enthusiasm and support. We are a project of 91.7 local public radio, K-A-L-W and San Francisco, and produced under the offices of Arksite, in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. You can find this show and hang out with other people who like this show on Facebook. All of us at 99pi are on Twitter, please follow us there.
艾弗里·特鲁布曼，以及我罗曼·马尔斯制作。对于我们节目来说，这是非常精彩的一年。非常感谢你们的热情和支持。我们是旧金山 91.7 本地公共广播电台 KALW 的一个项目，并在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心美丽的阿克斯特办公室的赞助下制作。你们可以在 Facebook 上找到这个节目并与其他喜欢这个节目的人交流。我们 99pi 的所有人都在 Twitter 上，请在那里关注我们。
We have a great Tumblr, but you're always welcome at our place at 99pi.org. Radio Tapio. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们有一个很棒的 Tumblr，但随时欢迎您来到我们的主页 99pi.org。广播塔皮奥。来自 PRX。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。